the infamous dinosaur predator t-rex
weighed over 6 tons and possess the
greatest bite force of any known
land-based animal then suddenly 65
million years ago t-rex and the
dinosaurs vanished from the face of the
earth for decades their disappearance
was a mystery
then in 1980 while examining rock strata
from 65 million years ago scientists
found a thin layer of a material called
iridium iridium is normally only found
in space so scientists turn to an
extraordinary explanation for how the
element came to earth it may have come
on a gigantic meteor they then figured
out that this meteor struck our planet
with a force ten billion times more
powerful than the Hiroshima atom bomb
creating a global catastrophe that
killed 70% of all species including the
dinosaurs the idea was originally met
with a chorus of skepticism then in 1990
scientists found the 112-mile Chicxulub
meteor crater off the coast of Yucatan
Mexico it proved a meteor had indeed
caused the dinosaur extinction and
revolutionized the way scientists
thought about the distant past
but could immediate impact have given
rise to the dinosaurs in the first place
it's a contentious new idea that's been
pioneered by a research chemist named
LuAnn Becker of the University of
California Santa Barbara
just as iridium provided the
extraterrestrial fingerprint of the
cheek Shalhoub meteor that killed the
dinosaurs
Becker has found something she believes
provides the evidence of the meteor
impact that gave rise to them
Becker's story starts here in Sudbury
Canada in 1996 Becker and fellow
geochemist Robert parada were on the
hunt for an extremely rare molecule that
they believed could only be created by
the incredibly intense conditions of a
meteor impact Sudbury was the ideal
candidate it had recently been
identified as the site were a meteor up
to 12 miles across struck the earth
nearly 2 billion years ago it would have
been a huge high-velocity
high-temperature high-pressure impact
exploding body
clues that Sudbury was an impact site
are still etched in the local rocks
quite literally and all of these rocks
if you take a look around you see these
really nice
shocked type features look like little
pyramids almost little teepees but they
they literally are the representation of
the the actual shock of the of the
impact the asteroid or the comment
literally hitting the earth